* Sanfte Bluesmusik *
"Mona mittendrin" -
drei Tage Expedition
in den unbekannten Schweizer Alltag.
Oh, wie geht ... Jetzt geht sie ...
Ich bringe sie nicht auf.
Ui, nein! Ui, nein.
Das wird bitter.
Come on! Ich habe
einen ganz schlimmen Verdacht.
Und zwar ...
Ich habe beim Schweizer Fernsehen
einen "DOK"-Kollegen,
der einmal einen "Reporter" machte
aus einem Bordell
und solche getragen hat.
Was ist das? - Es ist ein Ticket ...
- ... nach St. Gallen.
Zwei Buchstaben:
- BW.
Und einen Kompass.
- 62,8 km.
Wir folgen ihm einfach.
Also. Hey ho, let's go!
Ob sie schon bald
mit Girls an einer Bar sitzt?
Wir wissen es bald.
Ab nach St. Gallen!
Die Koffer sind gepackt,
das Handy darf sie nicht brauchen.
Ich bekam diese hier als ...
- (Mann) Oh ...
Und ich muss
nach St. Gallen St. Fiden.
Haben Sie eine Ahnung?
- Kantonsspital.
Das Kantonsspital ist dort?
Schauen wir mal, ob sie recht haben.
Ich habe noch keinen Plan,
was hier ist.
Ausser der Winter.
Aha.
Oh-oh.
Es ist nicht einfach ein Spital.
Das ist das Kinderspital.
Grüezi, guten Morgen.
Ich weiss nur,
dass ich hierherkommen muss.
Kennen Sie das: BW?
- Das ist sicher B-West.
Sie dürfen in den dritten Stock.
* Spannende Musik *
B-West.
Darf ich hier einfach so reinlaufen?
Grüezi.
Grüezi, guten Morgen.
Ich bin Mona Vetsch.
Vielleicht muss ich zu Ihnen,
aber ich weiss es nicht.
Doch, wir wissen es.
- Ah, das freut mich.
Willkommen im Kinderspital.
- Mona. Duzen wir uns? - Ja.
Ich habe etwas Angst.
Ich mag Kinder ja sehr,
aber kranke Kinder ...
... mag ich natürlich auch,
aber das wird wohl schwierig.
Weisst du,
auf welcher Station du bist? - Nein.
Dieser Teil hier, von Tür zu Tür,
ist die Kinderonkologie.
Krebsstation?
- Ja, genau.
Und zugleich Hämatologie.
Das gehört zusammen.
Wow. Wow.
Aber jetzt ...
- Wir gehen erst ins Kaffeezimmer.
Das ist Marina.
- Hoi, Marina. Mona.
Das freut mich sehr.
- Du kannst mit ihr mitgehen.
Das ist super.
- Wir sind heute zusammen unterwegs.
Mona Vetsch -
drei Tage auf der Kinderkrebsstation.
Auf nichts vorbereitet,
aber auf alles gefasst.
Das ist "Mona mittendrin".
Schau mal, Mona.
Damit auch du heute eine
richtige Pflegefachfrau bist ...
Muss ich mich umziehen?
- Richtig.
Im Kinderspital ist es so,
dass wir verschiedene Farben tragen.
Das ist extra für die Kinder,
dass ihr nicht nur weiss seid?
Genau.
Du darfst dir deine Farbe aussuchen.
Ich nehme Hellblau.
- Das ist doch gut.
Oh, schau. - Wir haben für dich
sogar einen Badge vorbereitet.
Damit dich alle erkennen.
Diese gaben sie mir mit.
Ist das funktional? - Ja.
Das war das Einfachste.
Ja.
- Ich kann kein Blut sehen.
Und bei Infusionen
wird mir schlecht.
Ich falle in Ohnmacht.
Du siehst, es wird schwierig.
- Wir improvisieren heute.
Wir haben auch Mütter hier, die
mit einem krebskranken Kind kommen
und sich
damit auseinandersetzen müssen.
Auch mit ihnen schaffen wir es.
- Das ist das kleinste Problem.
Wie reagiere ich, wenn ich weiss,
wenn ich ein Kind sehe,
von dem ich weiss,
dass es todkrank ist.
Das ist nochmal etwas anderes.
Ich kann mir noch nicht vorstellen,
wie ich reagiere.
Aber du führst mich da durch,
dann schauen wir.
Wir schauen einfach.
Du sagst, wenn es dir zu viel wird.
Abgemacht?
- Ja. - Super.
Wir gehen zu Mattia.
Er hat Leukämie.
Blutkrebs.
Wir begrüssen ihn.
- Weiss er, dass ich komme?
Ja.
- Und ich darf? - Ja.
Ist das gut?
- Ja.
Du desinfizierst fleissig.
- Das ist hier sicher wichtig.
Es könnte für ihn
lebensbedrohlich werden.
Eine Infektion,
eine normale Erkältung
ist für ihn lebensbedrohlich.
Gut.
Gehen wir rein.
So. Guten Morgen.
- Hallo.
Hoi.
Sorry, es kommen da gleich ein paar.
Ich begrüsse erst dich.
Ich bin Mona.
Mattia.
- Das freut mich.
Mona Vetsch.
- Bruno.
Bruno, darf ich dich duzen?
- Auf jeden Fall.
Super, vielen Dank.
Das sind die Blutwerte,
die wir heute abgenommen haben.
Sie sind alle leicht gesunken,
wie du siehst.
Die Plättchen sind auf 21.
Das Hämoglobin, die roten
Blutkörperchen sind gesunken.
Wir machen aber morgen
eine Bluttransfusion.
Damit können wir
noch bis morgen warten.
Ich hole gleich die Medikamente
vom Morgen, okay Mattia?
Hm.
- Das freut ihn weniger.
Oh, was musst du nehmen?
- Eklige Sachen.
Eklige Sachen? Was denn so?
Grosse Tabletten oder Säfte?
Es sind Säfte, weil ich
keine Tabletten schlucken kann.
(Schon nach 15 Min.
sind meine Berührungsängste weg.)
(Bruno und Mattia erzählen offen,
wie sie
mit der neuen Situation umgehen.)
(Papa liess sich z.B.
extra den Kopf rasieren.)
Sind sie schon ausgefallen?
- Nein.
Es ist noch schwierig,
es ist alles noch frisch.
Gestern vor zwei Wochen
wurde ich eingeliefert.
Heisst das, dass du
erst vor zwei Wochen erfahren hast,
dass du Leukämie hast?
- Ja.
Wow.
Und wie ist das?
Ich stelle mir das sehr ...
Wie war das für dich?
Erst hatte ich keine Ahnung,
was Leukämie ist.
Dann wurde es mir erklärt
mit den kranken Blutzellen.
Es war schon schlimm,
als ich erfahren habe,
dass es lebensgefährlich sein kann.
Ja, das glaube ich.
Und dann?
Was hast du gedacht oder gemacht?
Geweint.
- Ja.
Da wird einem der Boden
unter den Füssen weggezogen.
Ich kam von der Arbeit nach Hause.
Er kam weinend zu mir,
er müsse ins Spital.
Er sagte,
er habe noch so viel im Leben vor.
Er ahnte damals schon etwas.
Ja, das ist schon hart.
(Mattia steht ganz am Anfang von
seinem Kampf gegen die Krankheit.)
(Der grösste Teil der Chemo
kommt noch.)
(Und schon die erste
nahm ihn ziemlich mit.)
Seit er im Spital ist,
hat er 3 kg abgenommen.
Er müsste nun viel essen,
um sich zu stärken.
Fast Food.
- Viel Fast Food?
Soll ich dir aus dem McDonald's
eine Tüte bringen?
Ein Hähnchen. Er hat immer Lust
auf ein ganzes Hähnchen.
Sicher? Poulet? Poulet im Chörbli?
Das wäre doch etwas.
Hallo, zusammen.
Hier ist ja etwas los.
Petra.
- Hoi, Petra. Mona.
Saletti, hoi. Wie geht's dir?
(Die Ruhe und die Stärke von Mattias
Familie beeindrucken mich tief.)
Hoi, wie geht's euch?
(Aber nur stark sein aus Prinzip,
sei der falsche Weg.)
Zu Beginn hatten wir das Gefühl,
ich müsse ganz stark sein für ihn.
Aber auch die Pflegefachfrauen haben
mir gesagt, das muss nicht sein.
Man darf seine Gefühle zeigen:
traurig sein, weinen.
Es darf ehrlich sein.
Auch die Ehrlichkeit
ihm gegenüber.
Und auch den Geschwistern gegenüber.
Wir versuchen, möglichst
ehrlich zu informieren, was ist,
und spielen nichts vor.
Alle müssen wissen, was es bedeutet.
- Ja, ja.
So.
Genau.
(Krebsstation Kispi St. Gallen.)
(Lauter kleine grosse Kämpfer
lerne ich kennen.)
* Sanft-melancholische Musik *
(Wer hier ist, ist für länger hier.)
(Wer die Kraft hat, geht zur Schule,
wie der 12-jährige Schaim.)
(Eigentlich ist Schaim in einer
Spezialschule für Fussballtalente.)
(Aber die Leukämie machte einen
Strich durch seine Zukunftspläne.)
6 cm2.
Weisst du, wieso man Quadrat sagt?
- Nein.
Es sind zwei Dimensionen.
(Seit vier Monaten hat er
einen Chemoblock nach dem anderen.)
(Für jeden überstandenen The-
rapieschritt gibt's eine Belohnung.)
(Eine Mutperle.)
Du hast noch eine Perle zugute,
nicht wahr, Schaim?
Möchtest du eine?
Welche?
- Die grüne.
Aha.
Hast du dir schon
einen Chemokaspar ausgesucht?
Du kennst es schon besser als ich.
Hast du alle?
- Super, das geht schnell.
Sehr schnell.
Jedes Kind hat eine solche?
- Genau.
Jede bedeutet etwas.
Der Chemokaspar, der Chemoblock,
mit dem wir angefangen haben.
Manchmal gibt es auch Perlen,
wie diese z.B.,
die wie eine Tablette aussehen.
Das steht
für die schwierigen Medikamente,
die sie schlucken müssen.
Es ist etwa gleich gross wie 1 cm2
Bis später.
(Die Chemo bei Kindern ist oft
intensiver als bei Erwachsenen,
weil der kindliche Körper
mehr aushalten kann.)
(Beim Vorbereiten dürfen
die Pflegenden auf keinen Fall
mit den Krebsmedikamenten
in Kontakt kommen.)
(Für Gesunde sind die Substanzen
gesundheitsschädigend.)
Du musst
den doppelten Handschuh anziehen.
Sobald ich einmal
Chemo in den Händen hatte,
darf ich nichts mehr anfassen.
- Ja.
Bevor ich anfange, schaue ich,
ob wirklich alles richtig ist.
Die Medikamente
kosten schnell einmal
Tausende Franken pro Milliliter.
Wenn etwas falsch ist,
ist das sehr blöd.
Wahnsinn. Das ist so gefährlich,
aber ihr spritzt das
den Kindern in die Venen.
Also irgendwie ist das ...
- Es ist etwas paradox, nicht wahr?
Aber es ist in der heutigen Zeit
leider das Einzige,
was wirklich hilft
gegen diese bösartigen Tumore.
Leider richtet es auch
sehr viel Schaden an.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Das war's schon.
(Chemo - für die Kinder
Horror und Hoffnung in einem.)
Super.
Du hast eine hellgrüne Perle
ausgesucht. - Eine schöne.
Jetzt hab ich's.
- Ja! Das hast du gut gemacht.
Das hast du super gemacht.
* Sanft-melancholische Musik *
(Später am Tag bin ich bei Finn.)
(Er ist sechs Jahre alt und sein
ganzer Stolz ist seine Lego-Festung,
die er selber zusammengebaut hat.)
(Finn hat eben einen intensiven
Behandlungszyklus hinter sich.)
Wie lange seid ihr schon
zusammen hier?
Das ist jetzt die sechste Woche.
Und seit etwa fünf Wochen ...
... liegt er einfach nur im Bett.
Er ist nicht mehr aufgestanden.
- Ja.
(Aber jetzt
gibt es einen Lichtblick.)
Ich habe gehört, dass du
schon bald nach Hause darfst.
Hm-m.
- Was weisst du darüber?
In fünf Tagen.
- Fünf Tagen.
Wow.
Auf was freust du dich
zu Hause am meisten?
Auf die Katze.
Oh, schau! Hier ist sie ja.
Wie heisst sie denn?
- Nia.
Nia?
Wie habt ihr das organisiert?
Bist du Tag und Nacht hier?
Wie macht ihr das?
In der Zeit,
als wir im Spital waren,
also die letzten sechs Wochen ...
Ich war immer von Sonntagabend
bis Freitag hier
und mein Mann
jeweils Freitag bis Sonntag.
Es ist also immer jemand hier.
Immer. Ja.
Das wollt ihr so?
Ja, ich habe auch das Gefühl,
dass es sehr wichtig ist.
Für Finn.
- Hm-m.
(Plötzlich lebt man als Familie
in zwei Welten:
zu Hause und im Spital.)
(Die Krankheit diktiert den Alltag.)
(Seit zwei Wochen gilt das auch
für Mattias Familie.)
(Mattia ist das zweitjüngste
von fünf Kindern.)
(Wegen der Infektionsgefahr darf ihn
nur seine Familie besuchen.)
Ich habe ihm eben aus
dem "Fünf Freunde"-Buch vorgelesen.
Wir wissen, dass wir es jetzt,
so lange es noch so gut geht,
noch geniessen müssen.
Es kommen noch ganz andere Zeiten.
Das weisst du schon?
- Ja, das ...
Ja, im Verlauf der Chemo
wird das schon so sein, ja.
Achtung, der Schlauch!
(So schwierig
und doch so wichtig ist es,
als Familie
in diesem Ausnahmezustand
ein Stück Normalität
leben zu können.)
(Und auch im grössten Sturm
immer wieder schöne Momente
zusammen zu haben.)
(Im Kinderspital St. Gallen
werden jährlich rund
42'000 kleine Patienten betreut.)
(Zum Glück geht es bei den wenigsten
von ihnen um Leben und Tod.)
(Kinder und Eltern erleben hier
die ganze Palette von Emotionen.)
(Von Angst über Hoffnung bis Glück.)
* Sanfte Musik *
(Für Familien
mit einem krebskranken Kind
ist das Ostschweizer Kinderspital
nicht irgendein Spital.)
(Das B-West wird für Mama, Papa
und Kind zu einem zweiten Zuhause.)
(Am Tag ...
... und in der Nacht.)
Legst du dich zu mir hin?
- Soll ich zu dir kommen?
* Vogelzwitschern *
* Stimmengewirr *
Welche magst du denn? Frosties?
Die mag ich auch am liebsten.
Hat es hinten keine mehr?
- Nein.
Ah, dann nehme ich ...
Geht's gut?
Fast auf den Schlauch getreten.
(Ein neuer Tag.
Für Schaim ist es ein guter.)
(Er hat einen weiteren Chemoblock
geschafft.)
(Wenn es die Blutwerte zulassen,
darf er morgen
für ein paar Tage nach Hause.)
(Ein Aufsteller -
auch für die Pflegenden von B-West.)
Es ist einfach sehr familiär.
Jeder kennt jeden.
Alle haben eine Geschichte zusammen.
Das ist aber gleichzeitig
auch schwierig, oder?
Ihr lebt ja intensiv mit.
Um die Distanz zu wahren?
- Ja.
Ja, das ist immer ein Thema.
- Eine Gratwanderung.
Auch eine Auseinandersetzung
mit sich selber.
Wie muss man sein,
um gern hier zu arbeiten?
Oder warum habt ihr euch
dafür entschieden?
Wir kommen hierher und wissen
abends, was wir gemacht haben,
und dass es uns braucht.
Das gibt mir ein gutes Gefühl.
Ich weiss, dass ich etwas
gemacht habe, das jemandem nützt.
Etwas Sinnvolles.
Das gibt mir z.B. sehr viel.
* Alarmsignal *
Ihr müsst los, nicht wahr?
Ihr habt den nächsten ...
(Mattia hatte keine gute Nacht.)
(Er bekam einen Infekt.)
(Er kann kaum sprechen.)
Ihm schmerzt der ganze Mund.
Von der Chemo
bekam er offene Stellen.
Sie sagten uns,
das seien Nebenwirkungen.
Ei, ei, du.
Das hätte nicht sein sollen.
Es ging ihm eigentlich so gut.
Das ist jetzt doof.
(Vielleicht kann ja der leitende
Arzt Heinz etwas dagegen tun.)
Hoi, Mattia.
- Hoi, Mattia.
Und wie ist die allgemeine Lage?
Der Mund tut weh.
- Das Sprechen ist schwierig.
Und sonst?
Ausser dem Hals tut dir nichts weh?
Der Bauch ist gut?
- Nein, der hat Hunger.
Er hat Hunger,
und du kannst jetzt nicht essen.
Das wird nun aber schwierig für uns.
Der Bauch hat Hunger,
aber der Hals nicht.
Hier unten
gibt es ein schönes Konzert,
gute Darmgeräusche,
das klingt gut.
Heinz?
- Ja.
Sein Mutter hat mich noch
wegen den Blutwerten angesprochen.
Sie sagte, es wäre ihr wohler,
wenn wir alle auch
einen Mundschutz anziehen würden,
egal ob wir gesund sind
oder keine Infektanzeichen haben.
Was meinst du dazu?
- Das ist nicht nötig.
Wenn das Ihr Bauchgefühl ist,
können wir das machen, aber ...
Es gibt keine Hinweise darauf,
wenn man nicht hustet, erkältet ist,
ihn anstecken würde.
Aber Sie könnten morgen
erkältet sein und husten,
obwohl Sie sich heute
noch gut fühlen.
Aber dann bin ich nicht ansteckend.
Man ist erst ansteckend,
wenn man Symptome hat,
also wenn man hustet oder niest.
Da müssen Sie keine Angst haben.
Für dich ist das Wichtigste, dass
wir deinen Hunger stillen können,
und dass wir dir die Schmerzen
nehmen können. Ist das gut?
Also, bis später.
Tschüss, Mattia. Mach's gut.
Du warst eben bei Mattia.
- Ja.
Was ist eigentlich
der grösste Unterschied
zwischen einer
Erwachsenen-Krebsstation
und einer Kinderonkologie?
Es gibt viele Unterschiede.
Der eine Unterschied ist sicher,
dass immer
ein Elternteil dabei ist.
Ja, sie haben ja auch ihre Anliegen,
wie z.B. der Mundschutz.
Wie ist das als Arzt?
Wir versuchen oft,
auf diese Wünsche einzugehen.
Das ist nicht immer möglich ist.
Manchmal macht es keinen Sinn,
aber sie wissen nicht -
auch rein medizinisch -
dass es keinen Sinn macht.
Ein Vater z.B. wollte
keine Türklinke mehr berühren.
Er hatte so Angst vor den Bakterien,
wurde fast neurotisch
wegen der Angst vor Keimen.
Da müssen wir sie etwas runterholen.
Wir sagen den Eltern,
wie es aussieht.
Wir sagen gute
und schlechte Nachrichten - ehrlich.
Manchmal wollen Eltern Zahlen hören.
Also wie hoch
sind die Überlebenschancen?
Das mag ich nicht so, weil man nie
weiss, auf welcher Seite man ist.
Aber prinzipiell kann man sagen,
dass vier von fünf Kindern
geheilt werden. - Bei euch?
Bei uns und weltweit bei einer guten
standardisierten Kinderonkologie.
Aber das Fünfte gibt es auch.
(Die meisten der Kinder gehen ge-
heilt hier hinaus, aber nicht alle.)
(Bis jetzt machte ich
um dieses Thema einen Bogen.)
(Ein Kind verlieren.)
(Wie kann man
mit dem Schlimmstmöglichen umgehen?)
(Gerade auch als Pflegende,
wenn man die Kinder und ihre
Familien so lange begleitet hat?)
(Marina zeigt mir das Buch, in
dem sie diese Geschichten sammelt.)
(Jedem Kind
ist eine Seite gewidmet.)
* Sanft-melancholische Musik *
Wenn man sich das Buch anschaut,
kommen automatisch
Erinnerungen hoch.
Schöne Erinnerungen
und teilweise traurige.
"Nun sind schon fast fünf Wochen
seit diesem schweren Tag vergangen."
"Das Leben geht weiter -
muss weitergehen."
"Ich möchte mich
von ganzem Herzen bedanken
für viele Monate voller Liebe
und professioneller Pflege,
für tröstende Worte und Umarmungen,
für den würdevollen Abschied
und für das Licht auf dem Grab."
Das ist sehr schön.
Sehr schlimm und sehr schön.
Auch wie sie es dann - gerade das  -
in Worte fassen können.
Ja ...
Das gehört leider dazu,
aber es ist ein Teil,
den man gerne weghaben würde,
wenn man könnte.
Daran hat man gesehen,
dass diese Eltern
euch nicht weniger dankbar sind.
Es ist für mich eine Ehre
und etwas sehr Spezielles,
dass ich ihnen das ermöglichen kann,
und auch den Kindern,
die ich monatelang betreut habe:
ihnen die letzte Ehre zu erweisen,
in diesem Sinne.
Aber es ist etwas,
das einem extrem nahegeht
und das nichts mehr
mit Nähe und Distanz zu tun hat.
Sobald es um den Tod eines Kindes
geht, hat man keine Distanz mehr.
Dann geht man nach Hause
und denkt darüber nach.
Du siehst ja,
dass es mich jetzt noch trifft.
Es sind Bilder,
die man nie vergisst.
* Sanfte-melancholische Klänge *
Ja.
(Es gibt Dinge auf dieser Station,
die nur schwer zu ertragen sind.)
(Aber es gibt auch kleine Wunder.)
(Zufällig treffe ich Laura
und ihre Mutter auf dem Flur.
(Laura hatte vor zwei Jahren
einen Hirntumor,
so gross wie ein Hühnerei.)
(Heute ist sie gesund und kommt
zum letzten Mal in die Kontrolle.)
Das letzte Mal.
- Das letzte Mal.
Das ist gut. Zum letzten Mal.
Mama.
Es gab auch Zeiten,
in denen ihr nicht wusstet ...
Definitiv. Am Anfang
hiess es 10-20 % Überlebenschance.
Ehrlich?
Ja, da sah es nicht gut aus.
Wow.
Mama.
Und jetzt bist du gesund?
- Ja.
Wo kommt der hin?
- Weiss nicht. Vielleicht da?
Gab es auch Momente,
in denen du dachtest:
"Das halte ich nicht mehr aus"?
- Ja, oft.
Dann überlegt man sich,
was die Alternative ist.
Keine. Weitermachen.
Durchhalten.
Und es lohnt sich zu kämpfen.
Was ist das?
Da kommt der Rauch
vom Auspuff heraus.
* Sanfte Klänge *
(Kämpfen -
d.h. für die Eltern auch lernen,
die eigenen Grenzen zu spüren
und zu sich selber schauen.)
(Momente finden,
in denen man bewusst hinausgeht,
um Kraft zu tanken.)
Bis später. Guten Appetit.
Tschüss, mach's gut!
(Mattias Eltern gehen heute
zum ersten Mal
seit seiner Diagnose zusammen weg.)
(An ein Konzert
von Peter Maffay nach Zürich.)
Dann komme ich wieder.
Mitten in der Nacht.
Also, tschüss, tschüss.
Ihr geht?
- Wir gehen.
Ihr geht aus? Hoi und tschau.
Tschau. Freut ihr euch?
- Ja, mega.
Wir haben uns
erst heute entschieden.
Heute Nachmittag fragte er:
"Mama, ihr geht schon, oder?"
"Ich freue mich auch,
wenn ihr gehen könnt."
Tipptopp. Also, viel Spass!
Danke.
- Danke, danke.
Geniesst es. Tschüss zusammen.
Bist du am Gamen? Was machst du?
Und zwischendurch esse ich.
Fandest du es cool,
dass deine Eltern gegangen sind?
Ich finde schon.
Ich habe gemerkt,
wie viel ich ihnen verderbe.
Ich  mache alles kaputt.
Du?
- Ja.
Wegen der Krankheit.
Jetzt können wir
nicht in die Sommerferien.
Sie mussten ihr Wochenende absagen.
Darum finde ich es gut,
dass sie jetzt auch mal
irgendwo hingehen können.
Hey, du bist cool.
Wirklich. Und du machst
überhaupt nichts kaputt.
Ich finde schon.
- Sicher?
Etwas kaputt macht man nur,
wenn man schuld daran ist.
Dich trifft keine Schuld.
Sie machen das ja gern für dich.
Sie haben dich ja uh gern.
Das würde ich für meine Kinder ...
Glaube mir,
ich würde 100 Ferien absagen.
Das ist doch nichts wert,
wenn man Kinder hat.
Gell.
* Sanfte Klänge *
(Mein dritter Tag
im Kispi St. Gallen.)
(Schaim wartet bereits im Flur.)
(Er kann es kaum erwarten,
nach Hause zu gehen.)
(Aber zuerst
ist noch ein anderer Patient dran.)
Wir gehen zu Mohammad,
er spielt bereits hinten.
Schauen wir mal, ob ...
Aha! Mohammad?
Guten Morgen.
(Mohammad kommt ursprünglich
aus Afghanistan.)
Gut. Schau mal, das ist Mona.
Hallo, Mohammad. Ich bin Mona.
Schön, dich kennenzulernen.
Guten Morgen.
Das ist Herr Arozo.
- Ich bin Mona. Freut mich sehr.
(Auf der Station werden
auch Blutkrankheiten behandelt.)
(Die von Mohammad und seinen
Schwestern ist genetisch bedingt.)
(Einmal im Monat
bekommen sie frisches Blut.)
Oh, die Zwillingsschwestern
sind hier. Hallo zusammen.
Habt ihr euer Blut schon bekommen?
- Ja. - Ja?
Und, geht's gut?
- Ja. - Super.
(Wie dramatisch diese Krankheit ist,
sehe ich auf den Fotos von Heinz.)
(So kam Mohammad
zum ersten Mal ins Spital.)
Weisst du noch,
als du gekommen bist?
Da warst du ganz krank, nicht wahr?
Die Milz war bei ihm viel zu gross,
denn sie produzierte viel Blut,
aber krankes Blut.
Ja.
Wenn er
in seinem Heimatland geblieben wäre,
wo er die regelmässigen
Bluttransfusionen nicht bekommt,
wäre er
an dieser Krankheit gestorben.
Wirklich? Sie ist tödlich.
- Ja, eine tödliche Krankheit.
Nicht wahr?
Wir bekamen eine so gute Therapie,
er konnte operiert werden.
Da wurde die Milz verkleinert.
Ein wenig später sah er dann so aus.
- Jöh.
* Unverständlich *
Sie sind mir dankbar.
* Antreibende Musik *
Hallo, hallo. Wo ist Schaim?
Schaim
ist schon nach Hause gegangen.
Wartet er bereits hinten?
Aha! Wir suchen dich überall,
und du sitzt hier schon bereit?
Monsieur,
also, das gibt's doch nicht!
Das ist auch für dich
ein guter Moment.
Ja, das ist immer schön.
Wir waren vier Nächte hier.
Jetzt dürfen wir wieder nach Hause.
Ich schaue und plane
nicht zu weit nach vorne.
Was kommt noch, was gibt's noch?
Wir nehmen es Tag für Tag.
Es kommt immer ... Es kann ja
immer anders kommen, darum ...
Du nimmst es, wie es kommt.
- Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Super gemacht. Unglaublich.
Keinen Mucks.
Du bist befreit, Schaim.
Ab nach Hause!
Mach's gut! Bis nächsten Dienstag.
- Auf Wiedersehen. Vielen Dank.
Geniesst es. Meldet euch!
(Möglichst schnell raus -
zur Familie, zu seinen Freunden,
ins eigene Zimmer.)
(Drei Tage Glück.)
Hoi, geht's gut?
(Man würde so gern
richtig helfen können.)
(Aber alles, was ich machen kann,
ist etwas Kleines für Mattia.)
Du bekommst gleich selber Hunger.
Mattia, wir haben
eine Überraschung für dich.
Es gibt Mittagessen.
Für dich! Dein Hühnchen,
das du dir gewünscht hast.
Danke.
Er ist sprachlos.
(Mutter) Wow.
(Marina) Du kannst es kaum erwarten.
Guten Appetit.
Guten Appetit. Geniess es!
(Mutter) Sehr lecker.
(Marina) Mattia hat die letzten
Nächte von Hähnchen geträumt,
wie sie auf Wolken herumhüpfen.
Alles weg, Mattia.
Vorher klagte er über Bauchschmerzen
und Durchfall.
Aber mit diesem Hähnchen ist das ...
alles weg. Nicht wahr, Mattia?
Alles, alles Gute.
- Vielen Dank.
Hat Freude gemacht.
- Ich wünsche dir viel Poulet.
Für die nächste Zeit.
Nur wenige Scheisstage.
Und dass du möglichst bald wieder
in die Schule darfst.
Ich wünsche dir gute Besserung!
Eine gute Zeit.
- Danke.
Bis bald.
* Sanft-melancholische Musik *
(Marinas Schicht ist fertig.
Meine drei Tage sind es auch.)
(Ich gehe mit Gefühlen,
die ich nicht beschreiben kann.)
(Und mit viel Bewunderung
für die Kinder, ihre Eltern
und das Team
des Ostschweizer Kinderspitals,
die sich mit so viel Kraft und Herz
dem Schicksal entgegenstellen.)
(Ein paar Monate nach meinem Besuch
gibt es Neuigkeiten
von den kleinen Patienten.)
(Ich bekomme ein Foto von Finn,
dem Jungen mit den Legos.)
(Ein ganz anderes Menschlein,
das mich anlacht.)
(Der Weg sei weit,
aber es ginge bergauf.)
(Schaim,
der im Spital noch rumschlurfte,
kann wieder das tun, was er
am liebsten tut: Fussball spielen.)
(Und Mattia
ist zurück in der Schule.)
(Er hatte seinen ersten Tag
in der Oberstufe.)
(Euch und euren Familien viel Glück
und Kraft für die Zukunft.)
(Ihr macht das grossartig.)